she's managed to agree with her employer
that what she's going to do
is work part-time hours and work from
home
and she's able to do that and to juggle
that i think that anybody that's
thinking about having children
and is working for an employer that is
going to offer
zero flexibility to them i think they
need to be firstly questioning why
they're working for that employer in the
first place
but also i think there is a very very
strong argument because of covid and
because of what kovid's
done and shown that you don't have to be
in in the office
every day of the week you can do quite a
lot to maintain your career whilst being
a full-time parent constant learning
constant development
make sure that you're still keeping your
finger on the pulse of the industry and
what's happening
it doesn't mean that you've got to go go
to work or perhaps
do a little bit of volunteering or
keeping in touch days those sorts of
things
keep that keep that connection there
bye